what's up I just got out of the shower
so my hair is kind of all messy and
everything I haven't combed it or
anything and I probably won't for the
rest of the day because I'm not going
out but uh yeah I regret nothing but
what's happening everybody what's going
on we got back for another episode of
comics and coffee we are hanging out we
are keeping it real but what's up guys
um yeah so which series is better you're
a devil of jessica jones i think jessica
jones is better to be honest with you
guys if i want to be if i want to be
truthful um I think it's I think it's
better but anyway like like I'm so
disheveled right now I'm looking at
myself in the in the chat or I guess in
the video and and like I'm so disheveled
right now like like I really need to do
something with my hair I'll do something
after this but uh yeah like I'm growing
my beard out like I need to I need to go
get it trimmed like what it right on
here like this whole area right here oh
you guys are off on Thanksgiving break
badass that's right it's Thanksgiving
week this week isn't it it is
Thanksgiving week so here's my question
because I'm kind of curious how you guys
do stuff in school now because back when
I was younger um thanksgiving break was
like one or two days like I think we got
a couple days before thanksgiving and
then like the day after and then we have
the weekend so i guess we had to go to
school like one day that Wade you guys
is good like the whole week off I'm kind
of curious about how that works now for
for you young whippersnappers and for
you young people young folks
I'm curious but I'm like you every day
only you're worse the presence and the
one above all are the same guy know
there are two distinctly different
people let's see it was only two days
before Rob okay I don't know what it was
now i'm glad you enjoy my videos thank
you what is your favorite all new all
different model series so far The
Ultimates I love like cosmic level
events I love not not really like yeah
you meddling kids um I like the cosmic
events not in the sense of like you know
everybody fighting everybody on the
cosmic level but I like you know things
that have like cosmic entities and stuff
like that yeah this is the the secret
wars shirt that came with my collector
Corps like two months ago or whatever it
was but um no you're not blocked but uh
but yeah like you know I like the I like
that I like that element I like the idea
of cosmic entities and multiversal
threats and stuff like that like that's
just really fun to me and so I've I'm
always thinking that uh Rob do you plan
on doing any Star Wars comics no not on
coming to explain i'll be talking about
Star Wars stuff on Rob explains so so no
answer the captain britain he's not the
best superhero Walt not a chance but he
sees a cool character but he's not you
know it's black Marvel series done know
what we would be finishing out blue
marvelous it's actually a blue marble
I'm not sure if you were trying to be
funny or anything but anyway it's blue
Marvel and that series will be done like
we'll finish that once we finish
Deadpool vs. Thanos which the final
issue will be out today with a final
video for Deadpool vs. Thanos will be
out today and then tomorrow we'll finish
out blue Marvel and then we'll finish
the dark side war and go from there so
I'm debating on whether or not I want to
do the one shot so one shots look cool
I'm just kind of on the fence about
those so anyway um what do I think of
the Ghost Rider Ghost Rider is okay like
ghost riders decent enough your mom's
trying to get you to shave your scruff
here I mean if you don't if you don't
wanna shave your face don't shave your
face in and do what you want to do
life's too short what do I think of
Doctor Strange Doctor Strange is pretty
cool like Doctor Strange is
it's pretty awesome like I you super
powerful what's there to say he's the
guy they can do anything let's see Rob I
have a question why don't you put links
to videos you reference in your videos
well because you guys can just search
for him I mean they're on my channel
there's a search feature on my channel
you guys going to look them over if
you're interested that's why I say if
you're interested in looking at their
like check them out that means you know
it's a few keystrokes and a click button
away so um let's see Rob what other
youtubers do I like or do I that I watch
what are the youtubers there's a handful
of others there is markiplier I check
him out periodically I'll check him out
you know once every couple days or
something like that and n check out his
content um i watch like pewdiepie
periodically I like to his video blogs
more than the videos like his videogame
videos his video game video isn't really
for me I'm not really you know into the
you know the kind of the way that he
talks in his mannerisms and the way he
plays the games it's not really for me
but I do like his vlogs because he seems
like a really cool guy there's time on
Magnus who's hilarious there's hutch who
is a long time call of duty gamer from
way back in the day he was really really
gotta like pioneered the comedy
community to a degree there were a
couple guys before him xcalizorz blame
truth but hutches is one of my favorite
guys to go and watch sandy ravage
whenever he uploads which is like once
in a blue moon now and the mark of J
who's probably the best called any
player in the world that guy's nuts an
emergency awesome yeah I can't forget
about Charlie but yeah so emergency
awesome and also um name what's his name
I can't remember the name now mr. Sunday
which is under movies how can I forget
about him but I watches his channel
pretty frequently so oh the radbrad is
awesome radbrad is pretty awesome like I
like him he was Ivan burbeck when he had
200,000 subscribers respect when he was
launching his gaming channel now he's at
like two million or something like that
I think almost three million like he's
it's nuts how big his his channel is now
but um
let's see who do I think we'll end up
directing the Black Panther movie if I
had my choice I would pick the guys that
directed the book of eli i can remember
their names but um no god what was a
yeah what were there what was the name
of the guys that directed the book of
eli like somebody remind me who they
were i came over who they were but i
would select them to direct the Black
Panther film I think they'd be really
really good at it it's actually two
brothers who directed book of eli but um
do I think Captain America will die in
Civil War definitely got him strength
Superman how strong is he well he's a
god of strength but I haven't I actually
haven't read the one shots yet so people
are saying that like the Green Lantern
one shot is is pretty amazing um I'm
curious what do you guys think like like
what are your thoughts on the one shots
for Darkseid war I'm kind of curious Rob
do you plan on doing any Star Wars
comics not on economies to explain on
Rob explains I tried those on coming to
explain and there just wasn't a lot of
interests the Hughes brothers there we
go thank you I know you look at him I
know you did a Google search like the
book of eli directors like the Hughes
brothers it's the Hughes brothers Rob
come on man good lord but um no I am
Albert now on Hugh's okay no but anyway
I am I was wanting to do do Star Wars
comics on on here I can't explain but it
just didn't it didn't do that well on my
channel for whatever reason which is
weird because Star Wars is super popular
so i may try it again I mean I may do
like a one-off or something like that
i'm not really sure but i'll probably
just keep it confined to rob explains
which over there you'll find like the
you know like an actual according to
star wars the actual strongest Jedi the
strongest Sith the types of like what
lightsaber colors mean you'll find a
video on the origin of the Jedi I'm
thinking about doing a video on the
origin of the Sith which kind of ties
hand in hand with the origin of the Jedi
there's a few that I'm you know a few
that are that are coming out actually
right now I
have a okay what am i doing oh this sits
rule of 2 i'm doing a video on the rule
of two for the Sith so that is thus
that'll be pretty cool it's actually
still a tradition that's being
maintained in the force awakens so I'm
actually pretty excited about it from
best to worst Green Lantern flashes am
Superman yeah I've heard Green Lantern
is the best one you know I've heard
Green Lantern's pretty solid so um
planning planning to read dark tie three
I'm on the fence about dark 93 I might
read it but no no no I think in my
personal opinion The Dark Knight was you
know I guess the Dark Knight Returns was
you know like a it was lightning in a
bottle you know I don't think they'll
ever be able to duplicate what made that
story so cool because it came at the
right time it was the right story at the
right time the world was ready for a
transition to daughter comics and that
comic came out when it needed to and
Frank Miller just hit that one did solid
with it people loved it and and it just
kind of exploded from there but um not i
don't know i think they might be trying
to recreate lightning in a bottle again
and i'm not sure it'll work but i may
watch it or I may read it rather and
we'll see what's up so I finally made it
on these on one of these I've watched
all your videos one question has making
your videos change the way you talk in
real life no it hasn't but that's a good
question i need to get some water you
know just like my mouth is getting try
um that's a good question no it has not
changed the way that I talk in real life
honestly the way I talk in real life is
pretty much the way I'm talking now it's
vastly different than the way that do my
videos but scripting the videos you know
writing out a script on what I want to
say keeps things running smoothly it
keeps the the video pretty strong and it
keeps me from kind of going off on
nonsensical rants which is something
that I used to do before I had a script
and so having a script it was a really
really good idea plus it helps me convey
my thoughts a little bit better when I
can actually write them out and that way
I don't have to worry about going back
and remembering what it was that I
wanted to say because I've got it
written down so it's definitely scripts
are definitely a good idea but give me
one second guys I'm going to go
and grab some water real quick
oh man
okay then I'm back all right
you binge-watch jessica jones yeah I've
been watching the heck out of jessica
jones i believe this entry is dead last
I heard the Sentry is dead he's well
they have a version of him back during
contest of Champions I think but that's
the like you know the old school the old
school century not the new version of
the century I guess but what superhero
is my favorite this century well I guess
I think if story is more my favorite
than it is like him as a character being
my favorite but um let's see what's my
thoughts on Ben Affleck as a new Batman
do I think it'll be good yes I think Ben
Affleck will be a really good Batman
like I'm I'm pretty I'm pretty good bye
I think that I've been asked I gonna be
a pretty solid Batman like yeah I'm I I
don't really see why it would be bad I
mean Ben Affleck's come a long way guys
and Ben Affleck makes some really really
good movies and when you got our go you
got the town you've got a good will
hunting you've got you know I mean those
are those are really those three movies
throughout his entire career those those
are really really strong movies and so I
think he'll be a good Batman it just
depends on the script it depends on who
writes the script because at the end of
the day the actors just play the
character that's in a script and if the
script is written you know like you know
is written bad is written poorly then
you know it's gonna the movies going to
be bad you know but if his written well
then Ben Affleck will do just fine you
know so I think it'll be a pretty pretty
strong movie by the way guys say hi to
Mike Lawson he's trolling in the chat
trying to get attention so let's give
him the attention that he wants so that
he doesn't go hang himself or something
like that I don't know let's give him
let's give his life purpose Mike Lawson
mark larson that's what it is a smart
Lawson what's up mark lawson like we're
going to give your life purpose
everybody say hey to mark lawson but um
anyway my initials are the reverse james
that is pretty awesome
Matt Damon if Mark Lawson um if you
could have any two coming book
characters fight who would they be and
why ooh um man if I could have any two
color book characters fight uh well i
guess nobody cares about more clausen
okay i was gonna say i guess nobody
cares about mark well I guess mark
Lawson's life in this chat is like his
real life no one cares about if I can
have two characters fight I would have
like honestly captain america and Batman
and and here's a reason why Batman is
super smart um Batman is is you know is
a genius but he's also got a whole bunch
of martial arts behind his belt or I
guess under his belt you know and all
that kind of good stuff you know and
he's a solid character you know but no
I'm on the slim slow diet um but now um
you know I am I'm leaning more towards
captain america in batman because when
you have Captain America you know he
represents the you know the the might of
America so to speak but he's intelligent
he's strong he's super strong you know
he's a formidable fighter he studied
multitude of martial arts you know um
you know all different kinds of things
all right we're gonna we're going to ban
that mark lawson actually going to put
him in timeout we're gonna we're gonna
put him in timeout um we're going to
we're going to strip away his dignity so
um but yeah I definitely take Captain
America and Batman any day of the week
like I think they'd be a pretty strong
combat against one another so yeah slim
slow um let's see Rob you are an [ __ ]
leave the kid alone no that kid needs to
be made fun of that kid needs to take a
quick drop with a sudden stop we're
short drop with a sudden stuff like
that's what that kid needs to do um
let's see do you read god is dead and
i'm going to read got us dead I don't
know what got her dead it god is dead is
um does it have to be marvel vs DC
characters or any i mean i don't really
like doing vs because there's no real
room for discussion everyone doesn't
offer any you know significant
discussion like I like a good discussion
about a concept with vs it all just
comes out to who people like more you
know if you say like Batman vs Captain
America you know all the captain america
fans are going to say what Captain
America would win and all the Batman
fans are going to say well Batman will
win and that's just all there is to it
there's no there's nothing there to get
into so um how many words in the
dictionary includes able I have no idea
what a weird question I asked do you
think we will ever see a new version of
the juggernaut in a film or TV series
i'm honestly i don't think so i think
that I x-men three just like destroyed
the juggernaut as a concept because of
how badly he was written but no i don't
i don't see that you know i don't see
that happening you know I see that just
kind of like you know I see the
juggernaut going the way to be honest if
the juggernaut comes back it will be
because Xavier comes back and I don't
know if Xavier will come back he may or
may not but I don't I don't know um
let's see greetings from Denmark well
greetings oh you're in Louisville badass
you're like an hour away um let's see
we're series you have ever read ooh the
worst series i have a read
probably Geoff Johns Green Lantern now
I'm kidding I'm kidding before you guys
start freaking out no no no no I would
say that although the best comic book
series that I've ever the worst cover
book series that I've ever read um god I
don't know there's been any that I've
just said anything like this is just one
of the worst series that I've ever read
but probably Spider Island that was a
terrible line like that was an awful
idea just like you know yeah everybody
everybody likes your spider and your
spider and your spider and it was not
very good i didn't like it at all so um
let's see what is your favorite Marvel
now series are the ultimates definitely
I really enjoyed the ultimates puts the
raw what is your favorite DC character
hmm man
my favorite DC character uh I don't know
that's a good question to ask um I'm
probably Superman I think and and here's
why here's why I like to Superman so
much Superman has incredible power
depending on who writes him but you know
we can assume that the Superman let's
let's take Superman at his peak Superman
at the height of its powers are a Silver
Age Superman pulling like a chain of
planets you know all you know just
absolute craziness all right just the
kind of thing that he can do at the end
of the day Superman is still very much
fallible despite everything that he can
do and that I think is what makes you
perm and so fantastic is because his
power is a reflection of of everything
that people are capable of okay this guy
is spamming you get blocked um but he's
incredible despite everything that he
can do and you know he can make mistakes
he screws up he does things that he wish
he hadn't done you know um that I think
is you know is is what makes Superman so
strong you know because you represents
us he represents you know who we are as
people that we have this infallible
desire to get to keep going on we have
this you know unshakable foundation of
what makes and I don't mean in terms of
Americans I mean in terms of humanity I
mean in terms of people you know we have
incredible you know resiliency we have
incredible resolve we can face almost
any situation you know how we cope with
it depends on the situation but at the
end of the day he represents us as
people the foundation the bedrock of
what makes people so strong on an
emotional on an emotional and mental
level but at the end of the day despite
all of that stuff he screws up you know
he messes up he can be killed you know
he makes mistakes like that's one of the
reasons why I like him so much Batman I
think is is a really good character
because he's ground level you know he is
probably the greatest of the ground
level characters in in DC Comics you
know he doesn't have any
he doesn't have any powers he know
you're not blocked he doesn't have any
powers he you know has gadgets me as his
intelligence so he's just a guy you know
that goes out and does stuff and that's
that's cool in his own right but i think
the superman just represents something
so much more you know but um but I show
you show you my posters well I mean
there's those posters back there and
then there's couple posters right there
and then there's actually three that you
can't see off here to the side which are
the posters for episodes 1 2 & 3 so um
this can all be said about spider-man
you have a spider-man sucks so um let's
see um you're watching guardians of the
galaxy that's awesome I'm blue marble is
great but I think that no amazing zero
you're not blogged why do people keep
late am i blocked like you're like yeah
is like there's a million common still
coming through i'm not gonna be able to
answer everybody so you know um your if
no all right here's a question yet if
somebody posts up like if somebody post
in the chat am i blocked and you can see
what they say just say no you're not
blocked let them know real quick um
anyway Rob explains his apartment yeah
this tiny little part I just saw the
news that some people have been injured
in oh yeah that's cuz the batteries are
blowing up because it'll know how to
take care of their batteries thoughts on
Miles Morales Miles Morales is a great
is a great spider and character i really
like Miles Morales a lot more than I
like Peter Parker um you know Peter
Parker is it's kind of boring to me in
all honesty but that's because I really
can't relate to his character you know I
mean I'm not a white guy you know I
wasn't raised in Queens you know but
Miles Morales I can identify with you
know because I was raised in a very
heavily you know very heavy
african-american part of society and I
mean I lived in the corner of third and
race and lexington kentucky if you don't
know where that is go to google maps and
type in Lexington Kentucky like Wilgus
Avenue or what street I think it was tie
that end like that's where I live that I
lived in the hood you know of Lexington
which take the hood in Lexington for
what you want it to be but it's not but
nonetheless I was lived at office raised
in a really bad part of town
and you know I can identify with coming
from you know that kind of you know
struggle that goes with it and so like
his uh you know his character is
something that i enjoy but you know for
peter parker make a video I need to make
a spider-man sucks t-shirt now I'm not
going to do that I mean making it making
a video or something like that wouldn't
do anything but invite hate you know
it's just that the problem is if I get
on and i'll make a video and i say you
know my personal opinion is that
spider-man's not a very good character
people are going to be like well your
opinion is wrong and my opinions right
is nonsensical is that it is but um
let's see wait don't you don't get
notified when you why do people think
they were locked I'm not gonna review
maximum carnage Rob which comic book
character is the most esoteric in your
opinion what is esoteric mean I've heard
that phrase before but I've never had a
reason to look it up let's look it up
esoteric intended to be understood by a
small number of people um-hmm esoteric
which character is designed to be
understood by a small number of people
don't know why you could just say uh-huh
probably Deadpool Deadpool to character
that was I don't think was ever designed
to be funny to the masses I think dead
will Deadpool was a character designed
to be funny to whoever found him funny
you know because he was on the verge of
being cancelled all the time if you go
back and read Joe Kelly interviews Joe
Kelly's like hey man well we had when we
were writing Deadpool like he was going
to be cancelled at any point in time and
so we just basically ran with it and
just kind of created stuff and so he
just became an itch character um i would
i would go as far as to wager that a
vast majority of people who think that
Deadpool's hilarious have probably never
read a deadpool comic they just you know
their little bits and pieces here and
there and that's fun there's nothing
wrong with that um I just think that for
deadpool comics those are geared towards
a very small number of people so
um let's see Aquaman will be another
example I mean how many people really
care about a guy they can talk to fish
you know i'm sure those 10 Aquaman fans
are gonna get all bent out of shape for
me making fun of the fact that you can
talk to fish any idea why Marvel Max's
comics aren't on Marvel's website
because Marvel marvel unlimited can be
accessed by people of all ages and
marvel max is explicitly designed to be
geared towards you an adult audience and
so if you go into a comic book store and
you're clearly under 18 and you try to
buy a Marvel max comic they're gonna
turn you down um you know oh damn that
Jews back again well lets span that guy
I gave him a timeout you know but I
guess I guess spanking him sit him in
the corner like what's it wasn't enough
so um but anyway um new 52 Aquaman
kicked ass if you how come that is a
badass are coming it's great um don't
come for Aquaman do I think that there's
that the pool of again Aquaman movie no
I don't think there's enough interest
for an Aquaman movie not by a long shot
you know no he does not talk he talks to
fish all right he taught he tells fish
stuff and then like fish do it you know
you're going to call it suggestive you
know hypnosis if you want to but at the
end of the day he's communicating his
thoughts to fish all right I don't care
what you call it it seems talking to
fish I mean I hate to break the bad news
you know but that's just how it is is
there any Indian superhero any oh he
dropped the f-bomb well here let's
remove your ability to do that any
further always remember guys you're
welcome to say what you want to in the
chat just be respectful don't cuss and
you won't find yourself thrown into the
bandwagon so into the band get the ban
hammer just do it fish just go and do
stuff fish
but no like Aquaman talks to fish guys I
mean that's that's basically what it is
I mean he you know fighting global
warming the purple man of the sea it has
exactly what he is he's a purple man of
the sea he's making the fish go do stuff
um how long has just been going on for
for about half an hour maybe a little
bit less uh let's see do I like a
Jessica Jones Show oh yeah jessica jones
was amazing i'm kind of holding off on
Jessica Jones discussion for a couple
days because I know there were some
people that haven't watched it yet and
so I don't really want to ruin it for a
lot of people but um now like I you know
it was it was pretty solid yeah but Rob
you cus don't worry about me I make the
rules I can break the rules let's see
the banhammer do you think Emma will
ever return to relevancy I hope so the
ban hammer or Nothing gambit give it is
an awesome character um the ban hammer
is an awesome character Gavin is an
awesome character and I really he's
really kind of like he has a
devil-may-care attitude and I think a
lot of people you know like the devil
may care attitude of antiheroes you know
because gambits an antihero you know and
I think the idea of having gambit kind
of doing what he wants to when he wants
to but also having this kind of
undercurrent of yes he cares about
people i think is a really cool idea and
I think that's what made his character
so awesome the problem is is writing for
a gamut and at the end of the day guys
it all comes down to writing like it all
comes down to who's writing the story
chris claremont was a genius when it
came to writing extra medic colleagues
and a lot of that has to do with the
fact that he was taking taking
characters that were previously just
Unseld about and making them sellable
like that was you know a pretty strong
aspect of his character but um you know
I think that after Chris Claremont it
was really just people taking on the
x-men title doing what they could and
then just never really you know going
with it and I think that with the right
kind of writer you know if we had like
bindus for example writing the x-men you
know I think that he could definitely
bring back gambit and make him a really
really strong character you're in
Cincinnati also you're like an hour way
too but I think they can make him a
pretty strong and interesting
release you know ben de skun my mind is
in a million places I'm trying to read
and talk to you guys at the same time so
my mind just like it'll just like freeze
up all of us but I think that under band
of scam it could be a pretty strong
character so um let's see is this your
main job or do you have other job this
is my main job difference between name
or and Aquaman particularly what there
really isn't one um I guess you know
Aquaman is the king of the Seas the name
was a prince but you know that's really
kind of it so do I think apocalypse
isn't written to his full potential and
power oh now by chance not a chance you
know there's never been because here's a
problem if you were to have a story
where the x men fought apocalypse and he
was at his full at the height of his
power he was just you know straight out
he was going balls out on the x-men but
he would obliterate them easily just
came over you know because he's just
that powerful he would wipe them out
entirely isn't forge an Indian character
oh he's Native American the person that
they're talking about i think i don't
know if they were talking about any of
american but i think they were talking
about a person from like literally from
india from from Asia from from India and
Asia so I'm pretty sure that's what they
were referring to um let's see what if
they made Deadpool kills the DC Universe
I've been saying that for a long time
like I would read a story called
Deadpool kills the DC Universe he would
do that that kind of would sell like
hotcakes like it'd be amazing i'd buy
the hell out of that deadpool kills the
DC universe let's see if you didn't
youtube what job would you do I'd go
back to work at my old job definitely
although respite a man India that's
right um let's see thoughts on a young
justice TV show um I probably wouldn't
watch it to be honest I've never really
been a big fan of young justice though I
know that thousands a huge fan of like
those those teeny bopper you know things
those those you know teen shows young
justice and like you know the young
avengers and teen titans like I know
he's all about that kind of stuff
because of the drama the teenage drama
but I'm not a big fan of that kind of
stuff so um let's see do I like reading
comics on iPads definitely yeah like
reading comics on ipad is is pretty
awesome let's see that's like Kentucky
beating Duke why wouldn't we have Duke
sucks like if you're in North Carolina
and you're a fan of dude I'm sorry about
your luck but your team sucks um let's
see what was your old job Lionel job was
being a dispatcher and kind of
programming a little bit let's see Rob
who is Hal of the destroyer there's a
planet hala I don't know that anybody
named hollow the destroyer um let's see
you like Teen Titans yeah we need a non
lame Young Avengers all I agree about I
agree with that but the runaways the
runaways socks man i hate the runaways I
know if I was just like oh if that
receives this and he sees them where I'm
like man like like you know the runaways
suck he would just be like huh what um
let's see should they bring back the
original Teen Titans show I don't I
never watch the original Teen Titans
show that was after my time I was I was
really wasn't watching that kind of
stuff by then so um let's see for real
DC should jump on the idea of doing
their characters an adult swim and make
them aimed at adults Rob kills the
marvel universe like that'd be an
awesome awesome story I kill the kill
the Marvel Universe um I wish netflix
had captain captain in the game master
no idea who that is uh I'm not going to
do a video on the runaways what's my
favorite comic so far a dark side war
right now
were so good written might like rim by
Jeff Jones don't have or is amazing and
the way it ended too it's like oh my god
like I'm really psyched about it ah
let's see this house have a live show I
would watch that I think he live streams
every once in a while so hey Rob do I
think Benedict Cumberbatch will make a
good doctor strange in the upcoming
movie I think so but he's going to make
an even better one way model and
zoolander 2 i'm so gonna go see that by
the way I saw the Hunger Games the new
Hunger Games movie I don't know how many
of you guys have seen that but the new
Hunger Games is amazing like it was it
was really entertaining um let's see
what would you do if i had purple Man's
powers uh I'd live a life of luxury like
yeah I live a life of luxury um can I
explain more maestro I mean yeah because
the night show still exists postsecret
worse so I do a little bit on my show so
there's not a whole lot out there when
it comes to the maestro he's had a
handful of appearances and its most
notable appearance was in the original
future imperfect um but we'll see what's
up i mean i may or may not do some more
moisture so um let's say let's see let's
say you're Rob I'm sorry but I have to
leave well that's okay that's okay Brent
Britt McLean I like have somebody says
that like hey Rob I'm really sorry man
but I have to leave right now like I'm
sorry I have to go um ever consider
writing a comic for your fans I've never
I mean I don't think I'd write a very
good comic to be honest I don't think
I'd be very good at it so Rob what is
your opinion of Secret Wars doing that I
wouldn't say is doing bad so civil wars
doing pretty decent but no like I think
it's pretty I think it's pretty decent
and I thought that at all is the video
skipping really bad I mean it looks
pretty clean to me is anybody having
problems with the video like is it
freezing up or anything I've done
let me know if you guys are having
problems with it at all huh the stream
is lagging as hell well that's weird
there's this one I'm pretty smooth for
me oh really not skipping yes the
skipping yes I had to reload kind of wow
it's really laggy droppings of frames
surely I'm not dropping frames what the
fog drought yeah it is dropping frames
what's the dropping frames so bad holy
[ __ ] this dropping frames really bad
alright let's try that let's see how
that goes alright give me one second
guys it should be better now I don't
know why I was dropping frames so bad
wow I was shopping frames again what's
going on with YouTube's live streaming
it says it's good
that's weird
huh
well
I don't know that's weird that's weird
there's chopping frames like that no it
doesn't have anything to do with you
many people in the chat huh I'm too
popular now it doesn't have anything to
do with me people in the chat I mean
I've got maybe it's maybe it's a I don't
know
maybe it's a Time Warner Cable issue
because I got time warner cable all
right it should be better now let me
know if you guys are still at nope is
still [ __ ] dropping frames what the
hell all right uh yeah this is really
jumping frames really bad guys um like
we're gonna wrap this one up this is
gonna be a short one I'll try to figure
out why I was shopping frame so bad and
yeah so anyway um yeah sorry guys but uh
but yeah so I'm gonna we're gonna bring
this one to an end early and I will see
you guys next week peace